[Music]
thank you
this dude this this makes me so
uncomfortable
this editing Style
what is he watching
this looks insanely good though
Dude Perfect
he slams that [__] Lobster in there
that looks so good
dude how bad you think his [__] room
smells oh my God
would be so funny man the windows don't
open
[Laughter]
oh God damn it's not even fun to watch
because it just makes me stressed turned
into an old man dude what this [__]
meteor stresses now
you don't like a clean bed
sure yeah yeah
what are you saying I'm saying like that
doesn't piss you off or make you like oh
[__] don't spill any on your bed no
you're gonna get all over your your cool
shirt your beautiful sheets
I mean it's it's real now we've got an
intro that's a banging intro
now joining us in studio uh Brad Olson
principally infomatrix uh for a special
edition of girl Mass special now you've
heard these couple of segments Brad as a
principal Economist you're on the news
all the time we've nicknamed you bad
news Brad what do you think of the
segment girl mats look I couldn't I I I
understand why there's a need to justify
spinning in this economy that's for sure
Shannon and Carwin at the producers desk
are you ready are you a bit nervous
about today's girl mess with Brad here
no what is it because it doesn't matter
like it will always be justified it's a
lifestyle and it's a delusion yeah
um
yeah uh Nicole joins us good morning
Nicole hi now you you're considering a
new purchase uh and you'd like girl Mass
to justify this for you what are you
what are you looking at buying
I've already brought it but I need to um
justify to myself
how much did this uh did this Purchase
cost
330 and what is that
um it's a brand new new season Ruby
dress oh which one brand new new season
Ruby dress
[__] what brand new new season Ruby
dress brand new what which one are we
talking because that's going to help me
it's called the Ariel it's got a it's a
hole to neck it's got like shared fabric
down the side it's done it oh my God
it's all we pause it the idea is that
they're gonna have an economist like try
to justify this for the person yeah
that's kind of a good idea
it's a good bit how do you think let's
do it
um
I think the economist is gonna go
well your corner feel good in your cars
that's what I think he's gonna say add a
Patty and a Patty yeah you want to feel
sick you want to be able to network yeah
yeah
that's probably what it's going to be is
when you have something like that on
people treat you better yep
so when you're out at an event like that
you can Network everyone knows your
network is your net worth yep you ever
heard that little saying
and so that's how it's that's going to
pay dividends in the future much more
than 300 would so actually that
investment is a great one yeah it could
be one of the best investments of all
time could be it's like when you like
get home from a tour and you like
manically buy a truck
and then of trailer and then a trailer
yeah no
JK JK it is kind of like that yeah no so
that's paying dividends now yeah the
truck has purpose it does because you're
getting to the racetrack more yeah
spending more money there yep
which is
eventually it'll pay itself yeah
eventually yeah eventually yeah this
five-year project together all right
play
well I have three weddings coming up
this season and they're all different
people okay different crowds completely
different groups season three I'm
married to one of you and this is
[__] you were gonna wear that to one
wedding and you're gonna like get such a
nice photo at the first wedding year but
like well I can't now I can't wear it
because
this is called me a [__] the intention
today she's going to wear it three times
this is not a 330 dress brand it's 110
dollars
no we're not quite at free yet okay
um producers uh girl masks so look Ruby
I know a lot about and these dresses
will have resale value I know you look
him in the eyes Brad you don't believe
me but wait you're telling me she's
going to make money there is a market
for this yeah so if she wears it three
times yeah at 100 aware she can
definitely sell this after those three
wears for more than a hundred and ten if
you've at least saved one cost of
renting one dress so even if she sold
this it's 360 110 per wear even if she
sold this for 110 one of those wears is
now free she's wearing a free dress
exactly
actually do this
before they buy something
one lady in the back yeah do you
actually who said that
do you actually do this like in your
head you're like I never whenever I buy
something I'm like I just lit that money
on fire
I asked my sisters and they all said
that they do it
yeah
that's very interesting yeah
yeah I usually am pretty sad when I buy
something you know yeah it's like I
should shouldn't have [__] done that
you know I feel better instead of like
well I actually make sense I'm like I'm
stupid that didn't make any sense yeah
like when you spend 500 on CS go cases
you're like I'll just open them and I
won't get the money back yeah exactly
yeah
this is the polar opposite to me sports
betting yeah
that I'm like I [__] don't know [__]
I'm such a degenerate what am I doing
one thousand I need the sun I need this
money for other [__] I need this money
for other [__] what are you doing what
do you don't bet don't bet bad [__]
I know I'm gonna lose I don't know
anything about sports I suck
I [__] sucks so bad
yeah Lena
what's that thing we used to say
I [__] suck
such a [__] idiot that's me anytime I
buy anything anything
and your total is three hundred twenty
dollars oh yeah I suck
I thought you're smiling and then you
ring out and then yeah yeah I know it
sounds good thank you yeah tap or so
I'll tap
that I [__] suck
this is like incredibly wholesome this
clip yeah isn't it yeah it is if you can
get five ways we're talking about a 66
dollar dress now you get that from a
cheap shop but now you're buying a New
Zealand designer clothes
at Point Brad she's supporting the
economy the biggest question for me is
that the resale point is good how
important about the resale is good how
how long do you hold the dress when you
is there a commitment to sell it is it
commitment
I saw a [__] dress
yeah all right should we wrap it up this
is a horrible way to end it why goodbye
[Laughter]